shut the door go get me some water  though come back jesus christ yes you're  i'm a man i asked you to do something  you're a woman you go and you do it you  don't ask questions  so anyways like i was saying they're  sitting there [ __ ] moaning and  complaining about all this stuff they  don't have but we  you know and it's like you [ __ ]  outlive us  you outlive us well you know what you  have a birthday coming up i know exactly  what i'm getting you big bag of fritos  you're an [ __ ]  yeah so they're always [ __ ] moaning and  complaining about what they don't have  right  you know do they ever look around and  see what they do have a whole [ __ ]  platoon of shoes  huh that that guy paid for i'll tell you  what i have right yeah  oh  snap 12 to 6 right there baby  hey nian you know why i make more an  hour than you  because i'm better than you